Our world lead brings us to Ukraine now.
The fight in the city
with Europe's largest
nuclear power plant, at example,
is intensifying,
according to Ukrainian officials. There.
They say Russian cluster shells injure
eight civilians in a village nearby.
Three were ambulance workers
who had responded to the scene
in a predictable refrain.
Russia claims
it was targeting
deployment warrants
for Ukraine's military.
Meanwhile,
northeast of Aparicio,
Ukraine says it's clawed back
significant ground in back mud.
CNN's Nic Robertson spoke
to Ukrainian commanders on the ground
who want to set the record straight
on which Russian troops retreated.
First,
at the vanguard
of Ukraine's most successful
offensive in months,
elite soldiers stormed
out of the US, made 113 troop
carrier near back much
over the following three days.
They would take back close
to two miles of eastern
Ukrainian territory.
From Russian troops.
Their commander explains.
Dry ground.
New U.S.
attack
vehicles helping reverse months of losses
So
everything was planned
and calculated
and we had an advantage
because we used armored vehicles.
This time,
the weather gave us a chance to use
all our might
and show what we're capable of doing.
Yevgeny Prigozhin is saying
the reason new territory
is because the Russian forces ran away.
Prigozhin
Prigozhin is a liar
because the first to flee were Wagner.
It is his unit that fled.
And our success is not due
to the fact that they fled,
but the fact that
we conducted a planned
assault by circumventing
and cutting them off.
Actually, the unit he is bad mouthing
fought to the end.
His Wagners were the first to flee
Cleaned up and back from the battle.
Three young troop
commanders recalled the first moments
and their words.
Which were you a nervous
you feel the shivers, Allez says.
Every sound scares you,
especially the whistle of a mortar shell
with their success losses to
to move to each other.
It is
always painful
and hard to lose, Paul says.
But it doesn't stop us.
It makes us angrier,
tougher and gives us motivation
to go all the way and not stop.
Each of them knows more battles to come.
Morale.
They stand after each fight.
Morale goes up and down,
then up again, Trudeau says.
You have to motivate them somehow.
And this last battle
not done
when the Russians were pushed back.
They regrouped,
rushing in reinforcements.
Not for the first time in the days
long fight.
U.s.-made weapons
making a decisive difference this time.
High mass
precision rockets
reserve their reserves or too far away.
And this allowed us to destroy the enemy,
even as we approach them.
We used unmanned aerial vehicles
to see where they were concentrated,
which enabled us to use a hammer
for a precision strike.
His battalion estimate
in their sector of the fight.
Two to 300 Russian soldiers killed.
But he is quick to acknowledge
those soldiers strengths
and says Prigozhin is wrong to discount
the Russian army
so their offensive was so successful
in the hours of this morning.
Another attack was launched around back.
Morton Our commanders aren't saying
how successful
this part of the offensive is being.
And interestingly,
they're not saying
whether or not it's
connected with the big, bigger
expected counter offensive.
But significantly, on that.
Russia's defense ministry is saying
we're not losing any ground
around Bachmann at the moment,
and that's unusual for them to come out
publicly and say that. Jake, All right.
Nic Robertson in eastern Ukraine for us.
Thank you so much.
Meanwhile, a brash Russian
warlord and Wagner Army chief
Yevgeny Prigozhin says
Ukraine's counteroffensive
is already in full swing,
but Ukrainian President
Volodymyr Zelenskiy
says his country needs, quote,
a bit more time
to launch its counter-offensive
while he waits
for more Western aid to arrive.
Ukraine has gotten a new major delivery,
Britain's modern,
long range stealth
cruise missiles
capable of striking deep
into Russian held occupied territory,
which CNN's Jim Sciutto
was first to report
As Ukrainian forces
prepare
to launch a massive new counteroffensive.
They now have a deadly new weapon
in their arsenal.
CNN exclusively
first reported
that Britain
has delivered
to Ukraine
its advanced storm
shadow cruise missiles,
the kind of long range capability
Kiev has long been
pleading for the donation
of these weapons systems
gives Ukraine
the best chance to defend themselves
against Russia's continued brutality.
The storm shadow gives Ukrainian
forces the ability to strike
deep behind Russian lines.
A Western official called it
a proportionate response
to Russia's targeting
of civilian infrastructure.
However, Ukrainian forces have pledged
to fire the missiles
only inside
Ukrainian sovereign territory,
not to attack Russia itself.
While the U.S.
has so far
refused to provide Ukraine
with long range missiles,
such as the attackers
for fear of sparking Russian retaliation,
the UK has been more forward
leaning with its weapons
supplies in recent months.
The UK provided
modern Western challenger to tanks
before the U.S.
decided to supply its own Abrams tanks.
The storm shadow is a cruise missile
typically launched from the air
with stealth capabilities.
It has a range in excess of 155 miles,
three times the range of U.S.
provided missiles.
The Storm
Shadow's capability
is really complementary
to what
the Ukrainians
are planning to do
with their spring offensive.
It's able to use video imagery to target
actual areas that they're going after.
Still, the U.S.
secretary of state
has said that
Ukraine already has
what it needs to be successful.
My own estimation is that they
have in place
across all of those dimensions.
What they need to continue
to be successful
in regaining territory
that was seized by force
by Russia over the last 14 months.
Ukrainian President
Vladimir Zelinsky,
on the other hand, has said
his country is not quite ready
saying he is still waiting for aid
already promised.
We're expecting armored vehicles.
They arrive in batches.
We can advance with what we've got.
And I think we can be successful,
but we will lose a lot of people.
I think that is unacceptable.
We need to wait.
As I mentioned, Ukraine has pledged
to only use these new cruise missiles
inside Ukrainian sovereign territory.
That is not to strike Russia.
We should note, Jake, that
from the British point of view,
Crimea is very much an open target here.
They consider that
illegally annexed by Russia.
And that's strategically important
because these missiles
potentially put at risk
some of Russia's most prized
military possessions,
the Black Sea fleet,
the entire Crimea port.
That could be a real game changer
going forward as Ukraine plans
this counteroffensive.
Yeah.
Now,
we could mark this day
as as a day when decisions were made
that really changed things for
for better or for worse.
We don't know Computer, thanks so much.